>>> TONIGHT, NO SIGNS OF SLOWING
DOWN.
JACK SMITH, THE NEWLY NAMED
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATIONS, IS ALREADY
REVIEWING AND APPROVING ALL THE
FILINGS RELATED TO A KEY COURT
HEARING TOMORROW.
THE HEARING IS RELATED TO THE
MAR-A-LAGO CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
CRIMINAL CASE.
O
ONE SOURCE SAYING, QUOTE, THE
GRAND JURY DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE
SKIPPED A BEAT.
THIS IS A GROWING NUMBER OF
FORMER TOP LEGAL OFFICIALS SAY
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HEADED
FOR INDICTMENT.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, I
EXPECT THAT DONALD TRUMP WILL BE
INDICTED BY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> I PERSONALLY THINK THAT THEY
PROBABLY HAVE THE BASES FOR
LEGITIMATELY INDICTING THE
PRESIDENT.
>> "OUTFRONT" NOW, RYAN GOODMAN,
FORMER SPECIAL COUNSEL AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND
CO-EDITOR IN CHIEF OF THE JUST
SECURITY BLOG.
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES JUST PUT
OUT 169-PAGE SORT OF CHARGING
DOCUMENT AND VERY CLEARLY
SHOWING WHY YOU THINK INDICTMENT
IS APPROPRIATE IN THE MAR-A-LAGO
CASE.
AND THERE WAS WORRY 72 HOURS AGO
THERE WAS WORRY THAT APPOINTING
A SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR BOTH THE
MAR-A-LAGO CASE AND THE JANUARY
6th CRIMINAL CASE INVESTIGATIONS
WOULD SLOW THE WHOLE THING DOWN.
72 HOURS LATER HE'S APPROVING
EVERYTHING, THE HEARING'S GOING
AHEAD TOMORROW.
EVAN AND CAITLIN ARE REPORTING
THAT NOTHING'S CHANGED ON THE
SCHEDULE, NOTHING'S BEEN SLOWED
DOWN.
SO WHAT ARE YOU SEEING NOW?
>> SO THE REPORTING IS
CONSISTENT WITH HIS REPUTATION
THAT HE IS THIS KIND OF A DOGGED
PROSECUTOR WHO'S VERY QUICK AND
EFFICIENT.
HE'S A TRIATHLETE IN HIS OTHER
LIFE, BUT IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
THAT'S KIND OF AN ATTITUDE HE
TAKES TO THE WORK.
AND I DO THINK THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS BEFORE GARLAND'S
DECISION THAT IT COULD SLOW
THINGS DOWN IN THE ABSTRACT
HAVING A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
BUT THE PERSON IS SO IMPORTANT
IN THE EQUATION.
AND HE IS THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT HAS OBVIOUSLY HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING.
>> SO NOW TOMORROW'S BRIEFING,
JACK SMITH IS NOW FULLY BRIEFED
ON THAT, APPROVED EVERYTHING,
ALL THE DOCUMENTS WERE READY.
HE GOES
THIS HEARING IS ABOUT THE
DOCUMENT REVIEW OF THE
MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS, RIGHT,
THAT THE SPECIAL MASTER IS
SUPPOSED TO GO THROUGH.
THAT'S WHAT THE HEARING IS
REGARDING.
AND YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS
HEARING COULD BE VERY TELLING AT
THIS POINT.
HOW COME?
>> I THINK IT COULD BE TELLING
IN A CERTAIN SENSE THAT
GOVERNMENT'S POSITION IS VERY
STRONG.
THERE'S ALMOST LIKE A MENU OF
CHOICES THAT THE 11th CIRCUIT
HAS TO UPHOLD THE GOVERNMENT'S
CASE AND JUST ALLOW THEM TO
PROCEED AHEAD AND HAVE JACK
SMITH HAVE ALL OF THE EVIDENCE
THAT WAS SELECTED IN THE FBI'S
SEARCH.
THE GOVERNMENT IS STICKING WITH
THE SAME ARGUMENT THAT THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE OF DECLASSIFICATION
OF THESE DOCUMENTS, WHICH IS
TELLING BECAUSE THEY'VE NOW
INTERVIEWED KASH PATEL, WHO IS
THE ONLY PERSON OUT THERE IN THE
WORLD WHO HAS SAID OTHER THAN
DONALD TRUMP THAT HE
DECLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE STILL
STICKING TO THAT ARGUMENT POST
HAVING KASH PATEL BEFORE THE
GRAND JURY I THINK IS A TELL
THAT THEY'RE PRETTY CONFIDENT
ABOUT THAT IDEA.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO IN TERMS OF WHERE IT GOES
FROM HERE, THIS WHOLE OKAY,
WELL, THEY COULD CLEARLY SEEM TO
HAVE ENOUGH ON THE MAR-A-LAGO
CASE IF THEY WANT TO INDICT TO
DO SO.
THEN YOU'VE GOT JANUARY 6th
SEPARATE FROM THAT AND MORE
INVOLVED.
FROM WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT JACK
SMITH, WHEN DO YOU THINK WE
KNOW?
>> I THINK WE MIGHT HAVE
SOMETHING VERY SIGNIFICANT
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS ON
MAR-A-LAGO.
I DO THINK THAT THAT IS BASIS OF
FACTS THAT ALREADY PROVIDES FOR
AN INDICTMENT.
SO I THINK HE'S OBVIOUSLY
SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT GOING TO
SLOW DOWN IN THAT DETERMINATION.
AND THE BIG QUESTION IS DOES HE
MOVE FORWARD WITH ONE CASE IF HE
FEELS LIKE HE HAS ENOUGH FOR AN
INDICTMENT, OR DOES HE WAIT FOR
THE OTHER, WHICH IS THE JANUARY
6th MATERIALS?
AND THAT COULD BE A MUCH MORE
COMPLEX PROCESS.
>> AND THEN YOU WAIT FOR BOTH,
WHICH THEN YOU RUN THE RISK OF
LEAKS AND PEOPLE KNOWING WHAT
YOU HAVE ON THE FIRST ONE.
SO THERE'S RISK THERE TOO.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M JOINED NOW BY HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL PROFESSOR LAWRENCE TRIBE,
HE'S ALSO THE COAUTHOR OF "TO
END A PRESIDENCY THE POWER OF
IMPEACHMENT" GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO TALK
TO YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> I THINK IT WAS THE RIGHT
MOVE, ALTHOUGH, I HAD URGED
DOING THIS MANY MONTHS AGO IN
MARCH.
BUT MORE RECENTLY I THOUGHT THAT
BECAUSE MERRICK GARLAND WAS
APPARENTLY NOT REALLY READY TO
PROCEED THAT HE OUGHT TO PULL
THINGS TOGETHER AND BRING
INDICTMENTS.
THE EVIDENCE WAS CLEAR ENOUGH,
AND I THOUGHT APPOINTING A
SPECIAL COUNSEL MIGHT DELAY
THINGS.
HE'S CLEARLY FOUND A SPECIAL
COUNSEL WHO WON'T DELAY A THING.
HE'S HITTING THE GROUND RUNNING.
HE CLEARLY HAS ENORMOUS
EXPERIENCE.
HE'S COME RIGHT OFF OF THE WAR
CRIMES TRIALS THAT HE'S HANDLING
IN KOSOVO.
HE'S BEEN IN CHARGE OF POLITICAL
CORRUPTION TRIALS.
HE'S BATTLE HARDENED.
HE'S ABSOLUTELY READY, AND
GARLAND EMPHASIZED THE NEED FOR
SPEED.
HE'S CLEARLY NOT COME BACK FROM
THE HAGUE IN ORDER TO PRESIDE
OVER THE WINDING UP OF AN
UNSUCCESSFUL INVESTIGATION.
THE MARCHING ORDERS HE HAS ARE
TO CONCLUDE THINGS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, AND I TAKE THAT TO
MEAN A VERY LIKELY SET OF
INDICTMENTS ARISING BOTH OUT OF
MAR-A-LAGO AND THE ATTEMPT TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
>> WELL, HOW COMPLICATED WOULD
IT BE, PRACTICALLY SPEAKING, TO
BRING INDICTMENTS AGAINST A
FORMER PRESIDENT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, AND TO DO IT IN A
TIMELY ENOUGH FASHION THAT SOME
ASPECT OF THE CASE WOULDN'T BE
BUMPING RIGHT UP AGAINST A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION?
>> WELL, SOONER THE BETTER
BECAUSE THE DELAYS THAT ARE
BOUND TO BE PART OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S STRATEGY WILL MAKE
IT BUMP UP AGAINST THE ELECTION,
BUT MERRICK GARLAND IS NOT GOING
TO LET THAT DETER HIM AT ALL.
HE'S MADE THAT CLEAR.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SOMEONE
WHO THINKS HE CAN PROTECT
HIMSELF BY CLAIMING THAT HE
WANTS TO BE PRESIDENT, THAT'S
ALL FINE, BUT IT'S NOT UP TO
HIM.
INTERESTINGLY, HE SAID HE
DOESN'T INTEND TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE WORK OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WELL, THAT'S NICE.
NO ONE IS ASKING HIM.
IT'S NOT UP TO HIM.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS VERY
BROAD POWER, THE ULTIMATE
DECISION OF WHETHER AND WHEN TO
INDICT, AND FOR WHICH OF THE
MANY AVAILABLE CHARGES IS GOING
TO BE UP TO MERRICK GARLAND, BUT
WHILE HE'S RUNNING THE ENTIRE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WITH 115,000
EMPLOYEES, HUNDREDS OF
INVESTIGATIONS ALL OVER THE
WORLD, GARLAND CAN'T BE THE
PERSON TO HANDLE THE DAY-TO-DAY
DECISIONS IN THIS INVESTIGATION
AND THE PROSECUTIONS TO WHICH IT
WILL LEAD, AND THEY DON'T NEED
TO BE RUN UP THE TOTEM POLE
THROUGH THE BUREAUCRACY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BECAUSE
THE MARCHING ORDERS OF THIS
SPECIAL COUNSEL ARE TO REACH A
CONCLUSION AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AND
FAIRLY AS POSSIBLE, PUT IT ON
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S DESK.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, I THINK,
WILL LOOK AT IT AND HAVE EVERY
REASON TO APPROVE IT.
>> YOU BROUGHT UP WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD
NOT PARTAKE IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
OBVIOUSLY THAT ISN'T HIS CHOICE.
I MEAN, HE IS PRESUMABLY THE
SUBJECT OF THIS INVESTIGATION AS
IS QUITE CLEAR BY THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HIS LEGAL
STRATEGY WILL BE GOING FORWARD?
>> DELAY, DELAY, AND DELAY.
THAT'S ALL HE'S GOT GOING FOR
HIM.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS ANY GOOD
DEFENSES.
AT ONE POINT HE SAID HE WAS
GOING TO DEFEND AGAINST THE
CHARGES OF MISHANDLING THE TOP
SECRET INFORMATION BY SAYING
THAT IT WAS NO LONGER TOP
SECRET.
HE HAD THOUGHT THAT HE
DECLASSIFIED JUST BY THINKING
DECLASSIFIED.
THE TELEPATHY DEFENSE, THAT'S
NOT GOING TO GET HIM ANYWHERE.
AND WITH RESPECT TO THE ATTEMPT
TO OBSTRUCT THE TRANSFER OF
POWER TO PRESIDENT BIDEN,
LEADING UP TO THE VIOLENT
INSURRECTION, ORIGINALLY I THINK
HE WAS GOING TO SAY I DIDN'T
HAVE MUCH TO DO WITH IT.
I JUST MADE A SPEECH, BUT NOW WE
KNOW AS A RESULT OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE AND A
GREAT DEAL ELSE, WE KNOW THAT HE
WAS RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
HE WAS RECEIVING ALL OF THE
INFORMATION.
HE WAS ENCOURAGING THEM TO BE
VIOLENT AT THE CAPITOL.
HE WAS BASICALLY ABANDONING HIS
OWN VICE PRESIDENT TO THE
GALLOWS.
THERE REALLY IS NO GOOD DEFENSE
FOR ANY OF IT.
THE ONLY REASON HE HASN'T
ALREADY BEEN INDICTED IS THAT
GARLAND IS TRYING AND I KNOW
HE'S ALWAYS METICULOUS, WHEN HE
WAS MY STUDENT, HE WAS EXTREMELY
CAREFUL 50 YEARS AGO, 45 YEARS
AGO, I GUESS.
ANYWAY, HE'S TRYING TO DOT EVERY
I, CROSS EVERY T, AND NOW WITH
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL HE'S GOT
SOMEONE THAT I THINK IS GOING TO
CARRY THAT OUT, AND WE'LL SEE.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL NO DOUBT
GOING TO CHECK HIS REPORT CARD
FROM 45 YEARS AGO.
PROFESSOR TRIBE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.